German Chancellor Angela Merkel is now
hinting in a recent a series of comments
that she made that the United States is
increasingly just not an ally of Europe
but instead more of an adversary like
China and Russia which has to be dealt
with by Europe as an adversary rather
than as an ally and I know I know the
trumpets and the Nationalists and the
isolationists and the reactionaries will
say David Europe ha ha ha who cares what
Europe thinks were the best
we'll go it alone we don't need anybody
but this is actually serious this is
part of a geopolitical realignment that
is not good for the United States it's
happening as a result of President
Donald Trump and I'm gonna explain why
this is such a concern ok so first of
all angle Oh Merkel I'm to Angola
Merkel's left much to her left but she's
a skilled politician she's a powerful
leader she's respected by many of our
historical allies around the world and
when Donald Trump was elected we
actually did a segment asking who will
become the leader of the free world with
the United States laughably under Donald
Trump it was November 14th when we did
that story and my argument at the time
was that it would be Angela Merkel the
leader of the free world is of course
not a literal term it's a term that is a
colloquial term it dates back to the
Cold War and usually it applies to the
President of the United States or the
u.s. itself is sort of the Paramount
Democratic superpower and Donald Trump
as an embarrassment and as a destroyer
of geopolitical alliances is no longer
that leader and that leader
realistically is now on gala Merkel now
last week I told you that the superpower
triad of Russia China and the United
States is shifting in a way that is not
good for the United States if you're an
economic nationalist if you're a
geopolitical nationalist and you want
what's good for the United States
you see deteriorating us-china relations
with this constantly escalating trade
war while at the same time you see a
growing cooperation or Allegiance or
alliance rather between China and Russia
and that is a relationship that is
leaving the United States behind we
talked about that last week we now also
have Europe according to Merkel seeing
the United States more as part of those
adversaries like China and Russia rather
than as inherent and stable allies of
the European Union and of Germany and
this means that we're on the outs with
basically everybody at the same time and
that's not good for us let's look at
what Angela Merkel said quote there is
no doubt that Europe needs to reposition
itself in a changed world the old
certainties of the post-war order no
longer apply they meaning China Russia
and the US are forcing us time and again
to find common positions that is often
difficult given our different interests
but we do get this done think for
example of our policy regarding the
conflict in Ukraine our policies on
Africa to now follow a common strategy
which a few years ago would have been
unthinkable so we can't keep putting one
foot in front of the other
however our political power is not yet
commensurate with our economic strength
and the implication here is clear
European leaders more and more are not
seeing the Trump United States primarily
as an ally of Europe and why would they
and by the way remember when we had a
president when I as I watched Angela
Merkel give this speech and read the
transcript I was reminded of when we
also had a president who could speak in
a more sophisticated way not like a
fourth grader things have certainly
changed a lot every time I see other
world leaders speak I'm reminded of that
but in terms of the substance Merkel is
right to feel the way that she does
Trump ignorantly and irrationally
criticizes our historical European
allies Trump slams NATO Trump threatens
tariffs on the EU and European nations
and sets up another trade war similar to
the one with China that we can't win and
that is hugely destructive Trump backs
out of the Paris climate agreement and
is a complete non factor in the world
fight against climate change in which
Europe is a
player the United Kingdom is
increasingly at odds with the United
States and with Trump including over
Iran by the way which I'll talk about
next the world is increasingly getting
away from the US dollar as a reserve
currency Trump is considering
potentially disastrous military action
in multiple places including Iran this
is textbook Russia geopolitics if you
look at Russian geopolitical strategy
that they've been crafting for 20-plus
years everything is going exactly the
way they want now I'm not saying I want
to be clear I'm not saying Putin is
orchestrating all of this I'm pointing
out that this is out of the literal
textbook foundations of geopolitics for
what worse russia wants and benefits
from you've got an ignorant [ __ ]
president in the united states okay to
put it very simply you have the three
major superpowers US Russia China
increasingly positioned in a way that is
not good for the United States but very
good for Russia right the US and a
massive trade war with China to our
detriment while Russia slips in makes
nice with China and sort of puts us on
the outs of that very powerful
geopolitical triangle and meanwhile
Trump slams NATO which is exactly what
Russia and Vladimir Putin want and also
self harms our alliances with Europe
which is exactly what Russia and
Vladimir Putin want so we end up with
nothing and with no one and it's I mean
Putin has hit the mango jackpot here in
Donald Trump for lack of a better term
and the United States is both engaging
in geopolitical and economic policy that
is damaging internally and at the same
time being seen as the bad guy being
seen as the obstinate one that you can't
really deal with by more and more of the
world this is very very bad for the
United States and it is one of the many
reasons why this president needs to be
removed from power as quickly as
possible at this point I believe as I've
been saying for a while that the
quickest path to that is I don't even
have to say it we all know what it is
and it's about 1617 months away at this
point in time we've got to do that
there's a
really interesting segment from the
weekend we're conservative superhero ben
shapiro was interviewed by the BBC's
Andrew Neil and ben shapiro cut the
interview short over what he perceived
to be the liberal bias of the
interviewer and he's now ended up
apologizing it and the most interesting
thing about all of this to me is that it
happened because ben shapiro abandoned
some of his supposedly most important
principles he's against identity
politics and he's four facts over
feelings and in short ben shapiro made a
call the wrong call about the identity
of the interviewer as a lefty which
andrew Neil is not and that identity
based decision that ben shapiro made was
based not on the facts but on ben
Shapiro's feelings about the interviewer
which is the opposite of ben's facts
over feelings mantra so let's get right
to it
this is andrew Neal who was in the
conservative Club in college he worked
for the British Conservative Party he
was a correspondent for the conservative
publication The Economist and the point
is there is no a leftist progressive
streak to Andrew Neil by any means and
Andrew Neil asks ben shapiro to defend
things that ben has said he asked simple
questions and ben can't handle it he was
triggered that he wasn't given a safe
space on BBC so he implodes ends the
interview early let's look at one clip
first who were Ben's feelings sort of
get the best of him and he attacks the
journalist rather than talking about
ideas some of the ideas that are popular
in your side of politics would seem to
take us back to the dark ages
giorgia new abortion laws which you are
much in favor of that
a woman who miscarries could get 30
years a georgian woman who travels to
another state for an abortion procedure
could get 10 years these are extreme
hard policies well okay a couple of
things one i'm not sure i mean frankly i
don't know whether you're sitting are
you an objective journalist are you an
opinion journalist I'm a journalist ask
questions okay so you're a supposedly
objective journalist calling policies
with which you disagree barbaric
enacting only one side of the political
aisle
nice ideas so I just want to point out
that I know but you should at least be
honest in your own bias this is your
parenting are you are um everything in
America is not so polarized in one
program you only have the left and
another one you just have the right my
job is to question those who have strong
views and put an alternative to them
would you suggest that a late-term
abortion is brutal I'm not taking as
easily do more questions and eventually
Ben has just had enough and can't handle
it when his identity argument implodes
he does add homonyms that the
interviewer is less than Ben because Ben
hasn't even heard of the interviewer
that's a form of personal attack and ad
hominem and it really gets ugly and more
importantly very very stupid why is it
that a bill banning abortions after a
woman has been pregnant for six weeks is
not a return to the dark ages what's
your answer my answer is something
called science human life exists at
conception it ought to be protected now
back to my question to you you purport
to be an objective journalist BBC
purports to be an objective down the
middle Network it obviously is not it
never has been and you as a journalist
are proceeding to call one side of the
political aisle ignorant barbaric and
sending us back to the dark ages why
don't you just say that you're on the
left that's so hard for you why can't
you just be honest this is it's a
serious question
mr. Shapiro if you only knew how
ridiculous that statement is you
wouldn't have said it I just leave you a
question
and I asked you a question you failed to
answer a single one of mine frankly I
find this whole thing a waste of time if
you want to read the book and critique
the book why don't you read and critique
the book if you want to read if you want
to critique me you can think whatever
you want to me I don't give a damn what
you think of news I've never heard of
you yeah and I've never heard of you
until I brief myself for this but that's
not the issue you have it's an
interesting book but my point is your
book claims it from time to time your
book is called you I've done so several
times and I'm about to do so again if
you would let me just finish the
question you bet
turning on judeo-christian values what
are the values it's turning its back on
I you know I'm
inclined to continue an interview with a
person is badly motivated as you as an
interviewer so I think we're done here I
appreciate your time all right well we
thank you for your time and for showing
that anger is not part of American
political discourse now mr. Shapiro
we'll say goodbye so this didn't go well
Shapiro ended up apologizing to Andrew
Neal and saying that he misinterpreted
Neal's antagonism as political leftism
and this is a case study in why identity
arguments and letting your feelings
override the facts are bad ideas which
normally ben shapiro tells us is what we
should be paying attention to right
there's an identity argument here Ben
ended the interview over the perceived
political identity of the interviewer
not the ideas not the questions or the
issues being brought up it's sort of
identity politics in Reverse ben shapiro
is against the type of identity politics
that says my opinion is more valid or
particularly valid because of my
identity and i agree that when the
identity is used as a cudgel in that way
it's very bad and i've spoken out
against it but in this case Ben's taking
the identity politics position of Andrew
Neil's opinion is invalid because I
perceive him to be a liberal of course
Neal is not a liberal he also wasn't
taking a position he was just
interviewing Ben about things that he
has said it was a decision that been
made based on his feelings and not on
the facts Ben felt that hard questions
about his positions were leftist they
weren't Andrew Neil has a life of
conservative political credentials Ben's
being interviewed about the opinions
that he has espoused and writes about in
his book so why does he start asking the
interviewer for his opinions the
interviewer is interviewing been asking
what has been believed and it is a very
beta move when you start telling the
interviewer to give you their opinion
when you're unable to defend the things
that you've said during your life but
then the real miss point here is that
Ben tweeted something about being
destroyed by Andrew Neil or something
like that
this wasn't a debate right Neil was
playing the role of a journalist Neil is
personally conservative but he
identified problematic statements that
ben shapiro has made and he asked
questions about them and been lost
was not actually a debate because he
just jumped in assumed that the
interviewer had left-wing bias and then
uh yeah I guess Ben's used to getting
the kid gloves safeSpace treatment by
American conservative media outlets and
what Neal did was yes he quote destroyed
then but he destroyed him without really
do anything he just asked him to to
defend his claims and Ben was unable to
his feelings overrode the facts identity
ended up with Ben saying I'm out of here
and it is an extraordinarily fascinating
case study in how in many of these cases
the principles that these right-wingers
claim to espouse and hold up as the most
important thing grow out the window to
get thrown out the window no identity
politics well you ended the interview
over the perceived identity of the
interviewer feelings don't care about
the facts well it's not care about the
feelings rather
in this particular case been ignoring
the facts and letting his feelings
dictate how he behaved during that
interview which was by the way
extraordinarily embarrassing very funny
I wish they would just live up to the
principles that they espouse that's all
I'm asking for let us know your thoughts
about this will be posting about it on
our Instagram page at david pakman show
quick break back after this the White
House has finally put in place new
so-called rules for reporters who want
to be in the press room during Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is now very infrequent
press briefings and the new rules can be
used to kick out almost the entire press
corps if that's what the White House
decides it wants to do there's something
called a hard pass to the press room
okay a hard pass is good for two years
and it gets reporters in the press room
and on White House grounds the White
House doesn't want as many people to
have these two year passes because if
Joe the reporter or Sally the
correspondent asked a question that the
White House doesn't like in month one of
their hard pass tenure the White House
now needs to deal with this adversarial
person that they don't like for twenty
three more months until their hard pass
expires so what the White House is doing
is
making it much harder to obtain or to
keep those hard passes if they're
claiming it's all for security reasons
you'd have to be a [ __ ] to believe that
that's the case because if someone is
really a security threat the Secret
Service and the Capitol Police can
easily say they need to be removed even
though they have a hard pass because
they are a security concern so the new
rule is that reporters have to enter the
White House at least 50% of the days
over the hundred and eighty day period
leading up to the renewal which
basically means every other day but
there are not actually that many days
during that hundred and eighty day
period that those reporters would
potentially be going to the White House
and I'll explain because you might think
well there's a hundred and eighty days
the reporter needs to be there for 90 of
them maybe but if you are a White House
reporter for the most part things are
happening at the White House in terms of
briefings only on weekdays so you're 180
days two seven two sevenths of those
hundred and eighty days or weekends so
that already kind of gets you down to
only 128 weekdays so you've got to be
there 90 days out of a hundred and
twenty-eight weekdays so that means you
need to be at the White House 70 percent
of the days not 50 percent of the days
but if you're part of the press corps
the press corps often travels with the
president and once you start putting
together these multi day trips plus some
of the even longer ones that the press
corps attends to say that they have to
be there 50% of the day's ends up
working out to a huge majority of all
the weekdays that the president is not
traveling and this is a ridiculous
requirement and to go even further
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is barely doing
briefings these days she has had two
news briefings this year since January 1
2019
she went 59 days without a briefing so
you're putting in place a requirement
for reporters to have to go to the White
House on the overwhelming majority of
weekdays during which the president is
not traveling even though they're not
doing briefings and there's no practical
reason to be there
also that they can say you don't qualify
to renew your hard pass and if you lose
your hard pass you need to either get a
daily pass or a weekly pass or try to
get a six-month pass and right away you
become subject to the political whims of
the White House whether they do or don't
like your reporting
CNN's Jim Acosta sort of a perfect
example the Washington Post's Dana
Millbank has had his pass revoked this
week was notified via email says that
there are other reporters including all
seven of the Washington Post's white
house correspondents and we know that
Donald Trump doesn't like the Washington
Post politically so this is obviously
politically motivated it is yet another
way in which a Republican administration
that says they're for transparency and
says they are for all of the BS that the
write likes to claim to be for they are
actually one of the most authoritarian
anti media administration's that we've
seen and meanwhile they continue to
launch attacks on the Left claiming it's
the left who wants to suppress speech
that it's the left who doesn't want the
real hard questions asked and all of
this other nonsense that they're using
to bamboozle voters around the country
extraordinarily heavy-handed anti media
anti speech Pro censorship decisions and
if you believe that this is all about
security concerns I feel sorry for you I
don't know what kind of a fantasy world
you're living in that you buy that
explanation from the White House let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show follow us both all right
here's a story that I think a lot of you
will find interesting it's sort of an
internal media and punditry story Dave
Rubin was confronted by a couple of
students actually during recent events
one of the events was sponsored by the
right-wing organization Turning Point
USA and a student in this first video
we're gonna look at turn to Dave Rubin
and said among other things why won't
you interview or debate David Pakman why
won't you debate Sam cedar or Natalie
wind but eventually it got to why won't
you interview David Pakman and if you're
not familiar with Dave Rubin he's a
cultural critic and intern
sensation who opens the floor to the
Battle of ideas by interviewing people
mostly conservative people since he had
a political awakening in which he
realized that he didn't leave the left
but the left had let had left him okay
that that's sort of a summary of one
version of Dave Rubin okay anyway I used
to sort of be friends with Dave Rubin
and we would talk on the phone privately
I at one point had an open invite to do
his show sort of like whenever I'm in
Los Angeles I've tried to take him up on
that last time I was in LA it didn't
work it hasn't happened for a variety of
reasons and Sam cedar from the majority
report has actually been trying to
debate Dave I've been hoping more to
just have a conversation about ideas
that I think are good ones and that I
can defend with facts and he's not done
any of these interviews some say he's
dodging others say he's simply correct
not to interview bad faith actors like
me I guess or Sam cedar I don't know so
a student confronts him at Santa Clara
University a few days ago asks in about
about this let's take a look at how it
went hey Dave so I'm watching your
program since about like early time in
high school I'm in college so it's been
a while but one thing that I really
liked something that you talked about
here was the difference between I
diversity of thought and diversity of
identity sure now the thing with a
diversity of thaws I feel like that's a
problem you actually
to wave on your show because the only
time you really have left too many
guests are when there are members of the
intellectual dark bugs just heretics or
weinstein and they're only there for the
bulk of the time to talk about the
regressive love and so I pretty much
wanted to ask you why won't you have Sam
or Sam cedar on yeah it's recording okay
yeah he's just a dishonest player is
just lied about you so would you be
willing to have now that the win of
contra points or David pac-man or
Calculon ski all these are progressives
who are I'm not I'm not against having
any of them but I'm not gonna people
that attack me first I think it's pretty
obvious if you watch what I did up here
but I don't want attack people person
I'm happy to talk about ideas
you're gonna go up at University you're
gonna lie about a plan or anything like
that it's just how the game monthly
there's no winning you know I have a
certain set of rules when it comes to
talking to people and how I swear behave
as a public person so we call Sam a
dishonest player he's asked about me and
others and I guess he says in this clip
he's not in principle against it but
he's not going to interview people who
attack him personally or who lie about
him or who slander him and when I saw
this I thought he he can't be saying I'm
attacking him personally right or that
I'm lying about him I mean he he knows
me we used to text each other talk on
the phone he's no longer on the left and
I'm on the left but he knows I'm a good
faith actor right like I don't think
he's including me in that and just a few
days later at the University of Delaware
again he's asked about me and claims Pac
Man has lied about me multiple times
take a listen to this the audio is not
great but you can hear it alright can I
last one because I am 11 all right easy
questions is there anyone I know you
want to beat Sam cedar the majority
report is there anyone on the
progressives baby Pakman or from counter
points that you would be willing to have
a discussion
I know he you had him on the show once
man is lied about me many times so this
is super deceptive in a few ways I mean
first he says oh yeah I did have David
Pakman on he didn't have me on his
current show he had me on when he was
still I think it was on aura TV I had
done a piece critiquing reza aslan and
he had me on to talk about that it
wasn't like his current show since there
has been you know a clamoring for more
left-wing guests but more importantly
tell me the lies I told right if there's
anything I can be fairly criticized
about when it comes to my relationship
with Ruben it's that I've actually been
too nice and I've been too fair to him
in a sense I've been asked to comment
about him and to be interviewed for
multiple articles that I thought might
be hit pieces and I declined just on
that basis I specifically critique Ruben
without attacking him as an individual I
have not said anything that I knew to be
false about Dave Ruben I might have an
opinion that's wrong right for example
I've said I don't get how someone has a
complete political awakening at nearly
forty years of age where they go from
saying they basically like everything
Bernie Sanders is offering a few years
ago to you know the the kind of Ben
Shapiro etc etc right wing I don't know
how that's possible it's not an attack
it's my opinion I'd love to talk to him
about it and he can explain to me how it
is that he had such an awakening he has
my number
the first time I supposedly told a lie
about him if David texted me and said
hey Pac Man X was a lie or that wasn't
true or I had misspoken I would have
immediately said I apologize I don't
want to be spreading false claims about
people that are out there in the world I
stand corrected and I never would have
repeated that so-called lie again it's
never happened and now he says I've loud
about lied about a multiple times and he
doesn't name one I also think by the way
that it's very hypocritical I hope he
doesn't think this is an attack this is
just a critique of what he's saying it's
hypocritical to use this standard of he
won't interview people who make
personal attacks or our bad faith actors
because he does it all the time right
I'm not making a personal attack I'm
saying he makes personal attacks here's
an example of something dave has tweeted
out to a possible guest named Jack Smith
he said hey Jack you're an embarrassment
to journalism and that takes a lot these
days come on my show and I'll show you
what a real liberal is or better yet you
and Jordan Peterson face to face I'll
pay for your flight hotel and all the
soy you can drink not exactly the
catalyst to a civil exchange for the
betterment of human understanding right
another example to Sarah Silverman the
comedian who is politically on the Left
she had tweeted something about how
racists rarely think that they are
racist and Rubin responded just like how
entitled progressive celebs think
everyone else's backwards and stupid or
nah meaning she's backwards and stupid
but because she's a leftist she doesn't
even realize that she's backwards and
stupid
so for Dave to pretend that he's an
arbiter of civility as a way to decide
who gets on his show as a joke and
secondly the idea that I wouldn't be
civil is ridiculous I've had civil
discussions with white nationalists
Richard Spencer who believes that all
Jews like me should go to another
country
I had a civil discussion with Jesse Lee
Peterson who opened the show by saying
that the show started late because he's
black and black people are regularly
late and told me I am a beta male
because I'm a progressive and I still
manage to have a civil conversation with
him so if anyone on the list that was
given during these questions by the
students in the audience could guarantee
a civil discussion I would argue that
it's me maybe Dave's not pleased with
how our interview went the last time
that we did an interview which was years
ago I don't think he would agree to an
interview at this point will be
republishing that to youtube and
facebook at some point soon since the
wada you didn't see it but this is this
I don't believe that this is honest it's
not a personal attack Dave I'm saying I
don't believe that you're being honest I
want to talk with you about what these
lies are and then we can adjudicate them
let's have the conversation I may
actually be in LA relatively soon
I'll mention that if I'm going to be and
maybe we can actually sit down and have
this conversation so I told you
yesterday about the latest evidence that
Donald Trump completely and totally does
not understand tariffs sort of like at a
fundamental very very basic level but
that that lack of understanding doesn't
stop him from adding tariffs to China on
Chinese goods which of course as I
explained yesterday are actually paid by
American companies and by American
consumers and we seem now to have
crossed over into actual market panic
and volatility as a result of Donald
Trump's completely misguided and
harebrained economic policy when it
comes to tariffs and China and yesterday
stocks were tumbling I don't do much
day-to-day stock market coverage on this
show we tend to take a big-picture view
but the reaction and the chaos around
Trump's tariffs is important and I have
to talk about it
we saw the Dow Jones Industrial Average
drop a little over 600 points or around
almost three percent we saw a massive
drop in the Nasdaq we saw a massive drop
in the S&P 500 which is the broader of
those three major indices and this is
all because of this escalating trade war
that Donald Trump is waging against
China without understanding a thing
about economics without knowing anything
about trade and it's getting worse and
worse and very likely today stocks will
rebound as is often the case after these
major major drops and people will write
to me and they'll say David stocks
dropped yesterday but they recovered
today well more than likely you'll know
by the time you watch or listen to this
which because the trading day is still
happening today the recovery today will
not be as big as the massive drop
yesterday but the point is the massive
volatility day to day that the
president's misguided policies are
causing and I'm going to show you a
quote that tells us just how truly
ignorant Donald Trump is on this issue
of tariffs he said yesterday to White
House reporters we've never taken in ten
cents from China until I was elected
we're taking in billions of dollars in
tariffs I love the position
that we are in we've gone up a lot since
our great election what it means for a
country to go up a lot is is very dumb
and childish and stupid but the
fundamental misunderstanding is that
China doesn't pay the tariffs the money
that Trump is talking about taking in is
coming from American companies and
American people who are paying the
tariffs this is a dangerous man who
doesn't understand fundamentally basic
things this is weaponized ignorant
stocks are crashing trump's ad chair
trump adds to tariffs to china china
adds tariffs Trump adds more tariffs and
then the whole circle sort of starts
again and again and meanwhile China
forges other relationships while our
companies and our people get screwed so
I'm gonna try another approach on this
today because there's lots of people who
are apparently as confused as Trump is
on this issue because I get emails from
people saying David you're against
tariffs so you're a pro free-trade guy
free trades been a disaster for hundreds
of millions of people on this planet you
can't possibly be for free trade can you
David every single email I get that
attempts to make that economic analysis
forgets that countries don't exist in an
echo chamber the world didn't start in
2019 or 2018 if we were just starting
nation-states and setting up countries
today and economics and economies more
importantly didn't already have hundreds
of years of track records it would be a
philosophical debate over free trade
versus protectionism and that
philosophical debate would have
practical implications that's not the
reality right now we are mostly engaged
in a battle over principles of free
trade versus protectionism that are only
relevant in the theoretical and sort of
philosophical world where countries
haven't existed for hundreds of years in
the real world we have 200 years almost
200 years of industrialization and
specialization so the way that Trump
claims the tariffs will work will simply
not work and this stuff can be tough to
explain clearly
but if
you don't get this you can't possibly
evaluate these tariffs the idea of
putting tariffs on Chinese stuff to put
it really simply is if we make Chinese
stuff more expensive for American
companies American companies will choose
to buy American stuff to make their
products instead so in a sense you put
tariffs on Chinese stuff and it makes
American business more attractive for
internal production of different
products but the problem is that our
economy and those of many countries are
specialized and specialization is a
concept where countries decide we can't
make everything we can't make every
product we're gonna specialize in
certain industries or in certain
materials or goods or job types and
we've been specializing for a really
long time and in specialization it often
makes sense to trade with other
countries even when you have an absolute
advantage in all goods or in multiple
goods relative to other countries here's
a look just a super simple example from
economics one on one you got to
understand this stuff imagine a simple
world where you have two countries and
two products okay it's the US and China
and the two things that the US and China
can choose to produce are sweet potatoes
and cars okay really simple the United
States might be better might be more
efficient at making sweet potatoes than
China but growing sweet potatoes we
would say and at making cars than China
even if the US has what's called an
absolute advantage in both sweet potato
and car production it can still make
sense to specialize and only make one of
those and to get the other one from
China as part of a trade policy because
of something called comparative
advantage even if we are in the absolute
sense better at making sweet potatoes
and cars than China the ratio by which
we are better at making one over the
other would be different than that same
ratio in China in other words imagine a
situation where in the absolute we can
make more cars per day than China and we
can make more sweet potatoes per day
than China we might be significantly
better at Mae
in cars than sweet potatoes whereas
China might only be slightly better at
making cars than sweet potatoes and in
that case it would make sense for us to
specialize make cars and get our sweet
potatoes from China we have two hundred
years of this there are switching costs
there's competitive advantage there's
economies of scale
anyone who's saying are you for free
trade or not because free trade has been
bad or protectionism is good or bad
you're imagining this as a theoretical
and philosophical issue that doesn't
relate to the practicalities and in the
meantime Trump's ignorance is growing
the trade war this is bad for the
economy we knew it would be Trump has no
off-ramp from these escalating tariffs
and we're in very serious trouble as the
stock market and even Trump's own
financial adviser Larry Kudlow are
telling us let's talk about Elizabeth
Warren 2020 Democratic candidate
Elizabeth Warren has refused an
invitation to do a town hall on Fox News
and there's a lot to discuss here and
I'm very interested in many of the
elements that are going on here so you
might remember that not long ago weeks
was it a couple months times flying 2020
Democratic candidate Bernie Sanders did
a Fox News Town Hall and he absolutely
crushed it he had the entire room
clapping for Medicare for all he
schooled the moderators martha maccallum
and bret baier
on everything from health care to taxes
to economics i mean really just
everything it went really really well
for Bernie Sanders and it went really
poorly for Fox News Elizabeth Warren has
been invited to do her own Town Hall on
Fox News and she's taking a different
approach she has turned it down and she
says Fox News is a hate for-profit
racket that gives a megaphone to racists
and conspiracists which of course is
completely true but there's still a
question of whether Elizabeth Warren
might benefit in the net by appearing on
Fox News and talking about what are
mostly very good ideas that she has as
compared to ignoring Fox News altogether
now this is so funny there are people
attacking me on Twitter already like I
haven't even comment
on the Elizabeth Warren FoxNews townhall
thing I'm commenting on it now and
people are tweeting me saying David you
are gonna be a hypocrite because you
praised Bernie Sanders for doing the
townhall and you're gonna praise
Elizabeth Warren for not doing the
townhall but remember what I said when
Bernie did the townhall is I think that
there are two legitimate perspectives
here do the town hall knowing that Fox
News is the propaganda arm of the Trump
administration because you're making the
calculation that you'd rather reach some
portion of their audience that is
convinced about
even though it's a total hate for-profit
racket as Elizabeth Warren points out
that's a legitimate idea legitimate
point of view it's also legitimate to
say I'm not going to implicitly or
explicitly give attention to this
propaganda network nor allow them to use
me to continue their hate for profit
racket both are legitimate but you don't
have to take my word for it let's
actually look at what I said the day I
covered the Bernie Sanders town hall but
there were sort of two main arguments
leading up to this about whether Bernie
Sanders should or shouldn't appear the
argument against Bernie appearing is a
very simple one which is Fox News is the
propaganda arm of the Trump
administration it is not going to be a
town hall that is sort of fairly set up
it is going to be an audience that is
going to have hand-picked people from
political groups including turning-point
USA which happened it's going to be one
that most likely will turn into a
two-on-one sort of argument between two
Fox News moderators and Bernie Sanders
which it did and it's a net loss don't
give them the ratings by appearing that
was the argument against Bernie
appearing on the other side the argument
for Bernie appearing is listen these are
people who otherwise may never even get
a real understanding from Bernie himself
about what his policies are most people
not in the physical audience but in the
Fox News television audience probably
are not going to be voting for the
Democrat in November of 2020 but if
Bernie can convince just one or two
percent of the people in the audience
it's worthwhile and he could reach
people that otherwise will never have
anything break the
echo-chamber appears their propaganda
and therefore it's worth Bernie
appearing both the respectable and
defensible points of view so again both
their legitimate strategies each
candidate should handle it how they see
fit they don't owe Fox News anything
their calculation should be what do they
want to do how do they want to use Fox
News if at all to push their agenda and
to push their platform and if they don't
want to do it that's perfectly
reasonable now there will be all of the
normal responses to Elizabeth Warren's
decision that we can imagine and we
would expect Elizabeth Warren is scared
or she's avoiding debates and town halls
well Elizabeth Warren has done endless
town halls and she's faced countless
questions she recently took questions
completely unprepared when her plane
from I believe it was DC or LaGuardia to
Charleston I believe it was got very
very delayed she held an impromptu Town
Hall she's faced questions from
adversarial people and people on her
side saying that in particular she
believes Fox News is a bad faith actor
is very different than saying she's
afraid of or won't participate in town
halls or adversarial interviews you also
have to consider and this is something
that I've not seen talked about since
this story broke given how poorly the
Bernie Sanders town hall went for Fox
News I mean a roomful of people clapping
for Medicare for all and clapping for
Bernie Sanders on Fox News that's not
great for Fox News I would be shocked if
Fox allowed an Elizabeth Warren Town
Hall to go the same way that the Bernie
Sanders Town Hall went my guess is that
they would be much more prepared to
really make her look bad in a way that
they were unable to make Bernie Sanders
look bad now Elizabeth Warren is smart
enough and quick enough that she still
would probably do okay but I think that
that's also probably a consideration in
the last seven days as you may have
noticed I have been pushed more and more
in the direction of Elizabeth Warren um
I still find her quite uncharismatic on
a personality level I don't see her
really connecting with large swaths of
voters particularly well but as I told
you yes
today her policy proposals are detailed
most of them I agree with although I
have some questions about some of them
and since the fiasco that was the
handling of her DNA test she has been
making many of the right decisions and I
would be glad to vote for her against
Donald Trump and I would be glad to vote
for Bernie Sanders against Donald Trump
as well many similarities between the
two important differences which we've
discussed but there are some
significantly good candidates that are
running right now on the Democratic side
and good for Elizabeth Warren and this
entire but by the way this may have
inadvertently had the very successful
popularizing of the term hate for profit
racket about Fox News which has sort of
instantly been mainstreamed and has
appeared in all sorts of articles and
commentaries so good for Elizabeth
Warren good for Bernie Sanders I respect
both of their decisions but I would like
to hear from you do you think Elizabeth
Warren is making the correct decision
given all of the circumstances or would
you rather see her do you think it would
be the right decision for her to do the
Fox News townhall let me know on Twitter
at D Pakman make sure you're following
me and follow the show as well at David
Pakman show we'll take a quick break and
be back after this